so with that conceptual background I'd
like to attempt a description of empathy
that would seem satisfactory to me today
I would no longer be
terming at a state of empathy which was
in my earlier definition because I
believe it to be a process rather than a
state and perhaps that can capture that
quality the way of being with another
person which is termed empathic as
several facets it means entering the
private perceptual world of the other
and becoming thoroughly at home in it it
involves having sensitive being
sensitive moment a moment to the
changing felt meanings which flow in
this other person to the fear or rage or
tenderness or confusion or whatever that
he or she is experiencing it means
temporarily living in his life moving
about in it delicately without making
judgements sensing meanings of which he
is scarcely aware but not trying to
uncover feelings of which he is totally
unaware since this would be too
threatening it includes communicating
you're sensing zuv his world as you look
with fresh and unfriend eyes at elements
of which he is fearful it means
frequently checking with him as to the
accuracy of your sensing and being
guided by his responses you are a
confident companion to him in his world
by pointing to the possible meanings in
the flow of his or her experiencing you
help him to focus on this useful type of
referent to experience his meanings more
fully and to move forward in his or her
experiencing now to be with another in
this way means that for the time being
you lay aside the views and values that
you hold for yourself in order to enter
his world without prejudice in some
sense it means that you lay aside
yourself
and this can only be done by a person
who is secure enough in himself that he
knows he will not get lost in what may
turn out to be the strange or bizarre
world of the other and can comfortably
return to his own world when he wishes
perhaps that description makes clear
that being empathic is a complex
demanding strong yet subtle and gentle
way of being
[Music]